Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On the evening of Friday, January 30, 2004, hundreds of enthusiastic moviegoers crowded into the Nicarbaca Theatre in downtown Holland, Michigan. With a rich history dating back to the early 1900s, the 536-seat theatre had housed a wide variety of shows over the years. But none quite like this one. A group of film students from a nearby Christian art school named Hope
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。2004年1月30日星期五晚上，数百名热情的电影观众涌入了密歇根州荷兰市中心的尼卡巴卡剧院。这座拥有536个座位的剧院历史悠久，可追溯到20世纪初，多年来举办过各种各样的演出。但没有一场像这次这样。一群来自附近名为“希望”的基督教艺术学校的电影系学生
College were both excited and apprehensive to reveal the project they'd been working on so hard for the last few months. They scanned the room and took note of the audience. It was a mixed bag. Guests ranged from classmates to members of law enforcement and other esteemed locals. The movie's production had stirred up some big emotions around town and the community was eager to see it. Finally, the moment the students had been waiting for arrived. The lights went down and the screen lit up as the film's opening titles began. Classical piano music filled the room, followed by the mesmerizing sound of a woman singing. As the movie played, one observer, a member of law enforcement, was particularly transfixed.
学院的学生们既兴奋又忐忑，他们即将展示过去几个月里辛苦制作的项目。他们扫视了房间，注意到了观众。观众构成复杂，从同学到执法人员以及其他受人尊敬的当地人都有。这部电影的制作在镇上引起了巨大的反响，社区迫切想要观看。终于，学生们期待已久的时刻到来了。灯光熄灭，屏幕亮起，电影片头字幕开始滚动。古典钢琴曲充盈着整个房间，随后是令人着迷的女性歌声。电影播放时，一位执法人员观察者显得格外专注。
His mind raced as he absorbed every detail. After 80 minutes, the film came to an end. The credits rolled, but the audience remained silent and still, completely captivated by what they had just seen. Then the house lights switched on and the room suddenly erupted into tears and applause. Meanwhile, 80 miles away, one man did what he did every night. He picked up a glass and drank to forget. 25 years earlier, on Wednesday, January 31, 1979, the phone rang at the Holland Police Department in Michigan. It was just after 2 a.m. and a guest staying at the Blue Mill Inn across town had reason to believe that a robbery was underway in the motel's front office.
他全神贯注，吸收着每一个细节。80分钟后，电影结束了。演职员表滚动着，但观众保持沉默，一动不动，完全被刚才所见所闻所吸引。随后，室内灯光亮起，房间里突然爆发出一阵泪水和掌声。与此同时，在80英里外，一个男人做着他每晚都会做的事。他拿起酒杯，借酒消愁。25年前，即1979年1月31日星期三，密歇根州荷兰警察局的电话响了。当时刚过凌晨2点，一位住在城另一头蓝磨坊旅馆的客人有理由相信，旅馆前台正在发生抢劫。
He'd been on the phone with the motel's night clerk when he overheard an intruder barge in and demand money. The guest immediately hung up and ran into his colleague's room next door. When they tried calling the front desk again, the line was engaged. Police quickly arrived at the Blue Mill Inn. A two-story motor lodge located on Interstate 196 touted as the finest in budget lodging. Upon entering the lobby, officers soon discovered that $200 was missing from a cash draw behind the front desk, as was another $300 from a bank deposit bag in the back office. The front desk itself was unattended. The Inn's night clerk, a 22-year-old woman named Janet Chandler, was nowhere to be seen.
他当时正与旅馆的夜班接待员通电话，突然听到一名闯入者冲进来索要钱财。客人立即挂断电话，跑进隔壁同事的房间。当他们再次尝试拨打前台电话时，线路占线。警察很快赶到了蓝磨坊旅馆。这是一座位于196号州际公路旁的双层汽车旅馆，号称是经济型住宿中的佼佼者。进入大堂后，警官们很快发现前台后的现金抽屉里少了200美元，后办公室的银行存款袋里也少了300美元。前台无人值守。旅馆的夜班接待员，一名叫珍妮特·钱德勒的22岁女子，不见踪影。
Janet's purse was missing, her coat was still draped over her chair, and her half-smoked cigarette smoldered away in the ashtray. Police couldn't immediately rule out the possibility that Janet had voluntarily left the premises, but January was Holland's coldest month and snow blanketed the town. It seemed unlikely that she would have willingly gone out into such gruelling conditions without her coat. There were no eyewitnesses to the robbery, though the motel guest on the phone to Janet when the incident took place was able to provide some information. They described a deeper voice to man speaking to Janet, who told him, please don't take it all, sir. One person saw a vehicle outside,
珍妮特的钱包不见了，外套还披在椅子上，半支香烟在烟灰缸里冒着余烟。警方无法立即排除珍妮特自愿离开的可能性，但一月是荷兰市最冷的月份，大雪覆盖了全镇。她似乎不太可能在没有外套的情况下自愿走进如此恶劣的环境中。抢劫案没有目击者，尽管事发时正在与珍妮特通电话的旅馆客人能够提供一些信息。他们描述说，一个声音低沉的男人在与珍妮特说话，珍妮特对他说：“求求你，别把钱全拿走，先生。”有人在外面看到了一辆车，
but they hadn't got a good look at it. They believed it could have been a dark-colored four-wheel drive, possibly a jeep. Two sets of footprints were imprinted in the snow, leading from the Inn's entrance to where a vehicle had been parked. Sure enough, tire tracks indicated it was a four-wheel drive. Curiously, the Inn's front door was unlocked. This was odd, given that the motel had strict security procedures in place requiring employees to lock all doors after dark. Access to the front lobby could only be gained by buzzing an electric intercom. Co-workers confirmed that Janet was meticulous about making sure the front door was locked at all
但没看清。他们认为那可能是一辆深色的四驱车，可能是吉普车。雪地上留下了两组脚印，从旅馆入口一直延伸到车辆停放处。果然，轮胎痕迹表明那是一辆四驱车。奇怪的是，旅馆的前门没锁。这很反常，因为旅馆有严格的安全程序，要求员工在天黑后锁好所有门。进入前厅只能通过按电子对讲机。同事们证实，珍妮特一直非常细心，确保前门始终锁好，
times, but several guests recalled that the door had been unlocked approximately half an hour before Janet disappeared. It was fast becoming clear that Janet Chandler had been abducted by the robber, who might have ordered her to take her purse with them, assuming it contained money or other valuables. The scenario left police dumbfounded. Major crime was rare in Holland. Robberies weren't unheard of, but robbery involving abduction certainly wasn't a common occurrence. If the perpetrator just wanted a quick cash grab, why take the night clerk with them? Janet Chandler had surprised her parents when she announced that she'd accepted a job at the Blue Mill Inn. Her roommate and best friend, Laurie Swank, also worked at the motel and had put
但几位客人回忆说，在珍妮特失踪前大约半小时，门确实没锁。很明显，珍妮特·钱德勒是被抢劫者绑架了，抢劫者可能命令她带上钱包，以为里面有钱或其他贵重物品。这种情况让警方感到震惊。荷兰市很少发生重大犯罪。抢劫案并非闻所未闻，但涉及绑架的抢劫案绝非寻常。如果作案者只是想快速抢钱，为什么要带走夜班接待员？珍妮特·钱德勒宣布她接受了蓝磨坊旅馆的工作时，曾让父母感到惊讶。她的室友兼好友劳里·斯旺也在那家旅馆工作，并为珍妮特
in a good word for Janet. It was a strange choice for the Hope College student, who was studying vocal education with the dreams of becoming a music teacher. With a little luck, she hoped to one day work in the opera. Janet's parents, Jim and Glenner, thought their only daughter would be better suited to a part-time job elsewhere. Working as a night clerk sounded like a dangerous role, and they felt her skills could be put to better use in a different field. Janet had previously worked in childcare and studied nursing, jobs that suited her strong nurturing side. But Janet was adamant. She was eager to start making her own money to gain some independence. She was also feeling burnt out from so much studying, and was keen to take a semester off
说了好话。对于这位希望学院的学生来说，这是一个奇怪的选择，她当时正在学习声乐教育，梦想成为一名音乐老师。如果运气好，她希望有一天能在歌剧院工作。珍妮特的父母吉姆和格伦娜认为，他们唯一的女儿在别处找份兼职会更好。做夜班接待员听起来是个危险的角色，他们觉得她的技能在其他领域能得到更好的发挥。珍妮特以前做过托儿工作，也学过护理，这些工作适合她强烈的爱心。但珍妮特很固执。她渴望开始自己赚钱以获得一些独立。她也因为学习压力太大而感到精疲力竭，很想休学一个学期
from college to focus on work for a while. Ultimately, Jim and Glenner trusted their daughter to make the right decision. Janet was sensible and conservative with strong Christian values, and they supported her no matter what. Regardless, the break from studying seemed to do her good, and by the night of the Blue Mill Inn robbery, Janet had re-enrolled at Hope College part-time. With just one more year of hard work before she finished her degree, her dream of becoming a music teacher would soon be a reality. Jim and Glenner were awoken by the phone ringing in the early morning hours of January 31, 1979. It was the police, and they quickly filled the couple in on their daughter's disappearance. Much to the chandelier's dismay, they were asked
专注于工作一段时间。最终，吉姆和格伦娜相信女儿能做出正确的决定。珍妮特理智、保守，有着坚定的基督教价值观，无论如何他们都支持她。无论如何，休学似乎对她有好处，到蓝磨坊旅馆抢劫案发生的那晚，珍妮特已经重新注册了希望学院的兼职课程。再努力一年就能完成学业，她成为音乐老师的梦想很快就会实现。1979年1月31日凌晨，吉姆和格伦娜被电话铃声惊醒。是警察，他们很快告知了这对夫妇关于女儿失踪的消息。令钱德勒夫妇沮丧的是，他们被问到
whether there was anyone Janet might have run away with. Her parents strongly rejected this possibility. If Janet had up and vanished in the middle of a shift with no explanation, they knew something terrible must have happened. Jim Chantler was disappointed with himself. He had visited his daughter at the Blue Mill previously, and noticed some questionable looking characters loitering in the lobby. It had made him feel uncomfortable, and he now wished he had queried it more. The chandelers were advised to stay put. The roads were icy and dangerous, and the police already had a snow plow out looking for any sign of Janet. A blockade had also been established to try and prevent any vehicles leaving town
珍妮特是否可能与人私奔了。她的父母强烈否认了这种可能性。如果珍妮特在值班期间毫无解释地突然消失，他们知道一定发生了可怕的事情。吉姆·钱德勒对自己感到失望。他之前曾去蓝磨坊探望过女儿，注意到大堂里有一些看起来可疑的人在徘徊。这让他感到不安，他现在希望当时能多问几句。钱德勒夫妇被建议留在原地。道路结冰且危险，警方已经派出一辆扫雪车寻找珍妮特的任何踪迹。警方还设立了封锁线，试图阻止任何车辆离开城镇，
without their occupants being questioned. Jim ignored the advice and immediately jumped into his car, driving the dark back roads around Holland searching for his daughter. When Janet's younger brother Dennis found out what was happening, he joined his father in the search. Holland's police department was small, and all six of its officers soon gathered at the Blue Mill Inn. Despite being the middle of winter and far from peak tourist season, the motel was at full capacity. This was due to an ongoing strike that was taking place at the nearby Chemtron paint plant. In October, close to 200 Chemtron employees had stormed out seeking better work conditions. Union officials sought help from experienced
而不对车内人员进行盘问。吉姆无视了建议，立即跳上车，在荷兰市周围黑暗的后路上开车寻找女儿。当珍妮特的弟弟丹尼斯得知发生了什么事时，他也加入了父亲的搜寻行列。荷兰市警察局很小，所有六名警官很快聚集在蓝磨坊旅馆。尽管正值隆冬，远非旅游旺季，但旅馆已客满。这是因为附近的切姆特隆油漆厂正在进行罢工。十月份，近200名切姆特隆员工为了争取更好的工作条件而罢工。工会官员寻求经验丰富的
strikers who travelled from interstate to help on the picket line. The situation was very tense. Those who willingly crossed the picket line to continue working were faced with all kinds of harassment. Consequently, Chemtron was forced to outsource security to protect their property and keep the non-striking staff safe. They hired the Wacken hut security company, which contracted a team of approximately 80 security guards to work at the paint plant until the strike was over. Most of the guards lived outside of Holland, and the Blue Mill Inn became their temporary home. The no frills accommodation had all the basic comforts the security guards required between their intense 12-hour shifts, while the dive bar next door provided the perfect
罢工者的帮助，他们从州外赶来协助纠察线。局势非常紧张。那些自愿越过纠察线继续工作的人面临着各种骚扰。因此，切姆特隆被迫外包安保工作以保护其财产并确保非罢工员工的安全。他们聘请了瓦肯胡特安保公司，该公司承包了一支约80人的安保队伍，在罢工结束前在油漆厂工作。大多数保安住在荷兰市外，蓝磨坊旅馆成了他们的临时住所。这种简陋的住宿条件提供了保安们在紧张的12小时轮班之间所需的基本舒适感，而隔壁的潜水酒吧则提供了完美的
place to blow off steam. The bar became a meeting place for the Wacken hut guards, the strike breakers, and local single women. Despite the large number of guests staying at the Blue Mill Inn on the night Janet Chandler was taken, there were almost no witnesses to the robbery or abduction. All police had to go on was the description of the deep-voiced man overheard confronting Janet and the sighting of a dark coloured four-wheel drive. By the following morning, whoever had taken Janet had made no attempt to contact her family or claim a ransom. Police knew time was of the essence if they wanted to find Janet safe and well, but they had no way of knowing where to look.
放松场所。酒吧成了瓦肯胡特保安、罢工破坏者和当地单身女性的聚会场所。尽管珍妮特·钱德勒被带走的那晚蓝磨坊旅馆住着大量客人，但几乎没有人目击到抢劫或绑架过程。警方掌握的唯一线索是那个声音低沉的男人在与珍妮特对峙时被偷听到的描述，以及一辆深色四驱车的目击报告。到第二天早上，带走珍妮特的人没有试图联系她的家人或索要赎金。警方知道，如果想平安找回珍妮特，时间至关重要，但他们无法知道该去哪里寻找。
The only potential clue lay in another incident that took place just 40 minutes before the robbery at the Blue Mill Inn. At a liquor store just three miles away, a 20-year-old female employee had clocked off for the night. As she left the building, a young man attempted to grab her and drag her into his car. The woman managed to fight him off and escape and reported the incident. She described the assailant as a white male around 18 or 19-years-old who was 5 foot 8 inches tall with long stringy brown hair and glasses. Police wondered whether the same man could be responsible for Janet's abduction. A composite sketch of the suspect was distributed as investigators attempted to determine whether the two incidents were related.
唯一的潜在线索在于蓝磨坊旅馆抢劫案发生前40分钟发生的另一起事件。在三英里外的一家酒类商店，一名20岁的女性员工刚下班。当她离开大楼时，一名年轻男子试图抓住她并将她拖进车里。该女子设法反抗并逃脱，随后报告了这起事件。她描述袭击者是一名白人男性，大约18或19岁，身高5英尺8英寸，留着长长的棕色乱发，戴着眼镜。警方怀疑是否是同一个人对珍妮特的绑架负责。调查人员分发了嫌疑人的合成素描，试图确定这两起事件是否有关联。
Another potential link surfaced 54 miles north in the town of St Joseph. On the night before the abduction at the Blue Mill Inn, a four-wheel drive was stolen during a break and enter at a residential address. The green and white GMC Jimmy bore similarities to the vehicle seen at the Blue Mill. Officers around the district were alerted to be on the lookout for the Jimmy. As at near 1.30 am on the morning of February 1, 1979, a snow plow driver made his way along the dark highway near the city of South Haven, 30 miles south of Holland. There had been an inch of fresh snowfall overnight, and it was the plower's job to keep interstate 196 clear for motorists. As his headlights illuminated the snow-covered road, he noticed
另一个潜在联系出现在北面54英里处的圣约瑟夫镇。在蓝磨坊旅馆绑架案发生的前一天晚上，一辆四驱车在一次住宅入室盗窃中被盗。这辆绿白相间的GMC吉米车与在蓝磨坊看到的车辆有相似之处。该地区的警官被提醒留意这辆吉米车。1979年2月1日凌晨1点30分左右，一名扫雪车司机沿着荷兰市以南30英里的南黑文市附近的黑暗高速公路行驶。一夜之间下了两英寸的新雪，扫雪工的工作是保持196号州际公路畅通。当他的车灯照亮被雪覆盖的道路时，他注意到
something strange in the highway's median strip near the turnoff to the nearby town of Covert. There were fresh tyre tracks in the snow leading into a heavily wooded area. The snow plower got out into the freezing night air and followed the tracks. They brought him to a snow bank that was out in the open. There, underneath a fir tree, he saw a horrifying sight. Poking just slightly out of the clean white snow was the arm and torso of a naked woman. It was Janet Chandler. She had been raped and strangled, possibly with a rope, wire, or belt. Her hands and feet had been bound prior to her death, and her mouth had been taped shut. However, none of the bindings or tape were found on or near her body. Her clothes,
高速公路中间隔离带附近通往附近科弗特镇的岔路口有些奇怪。雪地上有新鲜的轮胎痕迹，通向一片茂密的树林。扫雪工走下车，进入寒冷的夜色中，顺着痕迹走去。痕迹将他带到了一个露天的雪堆旁。在那里，在一棵冷杉树下，他看到了令人毛骨悚然的一幕。从洁白的雪中微微露出的是一名裸体女性的手臂和躯干。那是珍妮特·钱德勒。她被强奸并勒死，可能使用了绳子、电线或皮带。她在死前手脚被捆绑，嘴巴被胶带封住。然而，在她的尸体上或附近没有发现任何捆绑物或胶带。她的衣服，
as well as personal belongings including jewellery, a wristwatch, a billfold, and her driver's license were missing. It was determined that Janet had only been killed approximately six hours before her body was discovered. There had been five inches of snowfall in the 24-hour period that she'd been missing, but her body was only lightly dusted with snow. Her clothes, as well as personal bodies, were only lightly dusted with snow. She had only been dumped shortly before the snowplow driver had discovered her. The case was bigger than the small Holland Police Department could handle. Complicating matters further was the fact that the abduction occurred in Ottawa County, whereas Janet's body was found in Van Buren County. This meant that different
以及包括珠宝、手表、钱包和驾照在内的个人物品都不见了。经确定，珍妮特在尸体被发现前大约六小时才被杀害。在她失踪的24小时内下了五英寸的雪，但她的尸体上只有薄薄的一层雪。她的衣服和个人物品上只有薄薄的一层雪。她是在扫雪车司机发现她之前不久才被抛尸的。此案规模超出了荷兰小警察局的处理能力。更复杂的是，绑架发生在渥太华县，而珍妮特的尸体是在范布伦县发现的。这意味着不同的
departments were responsible for different facets of the investigation. Dozens of detectives and uniformed officers were brought in from out of town and helped coordinate a major search of the area where Janet's body was found. Sniffer dogs and helicopters scoured the surroundings, however not a single piece of evidence was found. Motorists were asked to report any vehicles seen parked near the covert turnoff between 9 p.m. Wednesday and 1 30 a.m. Thursday. Nobody came forward. A potential breakthrough occurred when the green and white GMC Jimmy, stolen from St Joseph's the night before Janet's abduction, was recovered. The thief was revealed to be the owner's 18-year-old grandson. The tires of the Jimmy were compared to the tire tracks leading to the
部门负责调查的不同方面。数十名侦探和制服警官从外地调来，协助协调对发现珍妮特尸体区域的大规模搜查。嗅探犬和直升机搜寻了周围环境，但没有发现任何证据。警方要求驾车者报告周三晚上9点到周四凌晨1点30分之间在科弗特岔路口附近停放的任何车辆。没有人站出来。当那辆前一天晚上在圣约瑟夫被盗的绿白相间GMC吉米车被找回时，出现了一个潜在的突破口。小偷被发现是车主18岁的孙子。吉米车的轮胎与通往
snowbank where Janet's body was found. They weren't a match. The stolen Jimmy was ruled out of the investigation, although police remained adamant that a four-wheel drive of some sort had been used in Janet's abduction. News of Janet's murder utterly shook the small town. Terrified Hope College students lived in fear that a killer targeting young women was on the loose and they were advised to exercise caution. Encouraged by a $1,000 reward for information leading to an arrest, an influx of tip-offs came through from all over the country. One concerned citizen was in a bar when they overheard a group of men boasting about their involvement in Janet's murder. Yet when police looked into this report, they concluded the
发现珍妮特尸体的雪堆的轮胎痕迹进行了比对。它们不匹配。被盗的吉米车被排除在调查之外，尽管警方仍然坚信某种四驱车被用于珍妮特的绑架。珍妮特被谋杀的消息彻底震撼了这个小镇。恐惧的希望学院学生生活在担心有针对年轻女性的杀手逍遥法外的恐惧中，他们被建议保持谨慎。在1000美元悬赏金的鼓励下，来自全国各地的举报信息蜂拥而至。一位忧心忡忡的市民在酒吧里听到一群男人吹嘘他们参与了珍妮特的谋杀案。然而，当警方调查这份报告时，他们得出结论，
drunken men were just joking in very poor taste. Not one of the many tip-offs led to a promising suspect. The question still remained, who killed Janet Chandler? The respectable college student had no known enemies or nefarious links. She had been brought up in a wholesome family and the majority of her friends were from church. Although she had dated men in the past, Janet's family said she didn't have any serious boyfriends. They couldn't think of anyone who would wish her harm. Perhaps Janet was randomly targeted. It seemed as though she didn't know her abductor as she was overheard calling him Sir instead of his name. Was he an outsider passing through town who fled immediately after committing the opportunistic crime?
醉酒的男人们只是在开非常恶劣的玩笑。众多的举报中没有一条指向有希望的嫌疑人。问题依然存在，谁杀了珍妮特·钱德勒？这位受人尊敬的大学生没有已知的敌人或邪恶的联系。她在一个健康的家庭中长大，她的大多数朋友都来自教会。虽然她过去曾与男性约会，但珍妮特的家人说她没有认真的男朋友。他们想不出有谁会伤害她。也许珍妮特是随机被盯上的。看起来她并不认识绑架者，因为有人听到她称呼他为“先生”而不是他的名字。他是一个路过小镇并在犯下机会主义罪行后立即逃跑的外地人吗？
He could have been one of the many visitors to the Blue Mill Inn, though none of the guests could highlight anyone particularly suspicious. Some town's folk looked inward, certain the person responsible was among the local community. He might have worn a mask to avoid Janet's recognition. Was the robbery just a ruse to throw police off the killer's tail? Another theory emerged that Janet may have accidentally been killed while being held captive. One detective believed that the way she was tied up indicated she might have accidentally strangled herself while trying to break free. If this was the case, the killer might have dumped her body out of sheer panic. It seemed like everyone had a theory, but nobody had the answers.
他可能是蓝磨坊旅馆的众多访客之一，尽管没有客人能指出任何特别可疑的人。一些镇民向内审视，确信负责的人就在当地社区中。他可能戴着面具以避免被珍妮特认出。抢劫只是为了转移警方对杀手追踪的诡计吗？另一种理论出现，即珍妮特可能在被囚禁时意外死亡。一位侦探认为，她被捆绑的方式表明她可能在试图挣脱时意外勒死了自己。如果是这样，杀手可能出于恐慌抛弃了她的尸体。似乎每个人都有一个理论，但没有人有答案。
A memorial for Janet Chandler was held at Hope College, during which the school's president commented. An event such as this touches our deepest thoughts and emotions. Questions of why flood our minds with no ready or satisfying answers, and there is relatively little anyone can say. We trust that God will give Janet's family and, to all her friends, a special measure of grace and strength at this time. Two weeks after Janet's murder, the strike at the Chemtron paint plant finally came to an end, and the Wackenhart security guards scattered back to their hometowns. Things quietened down around Holland, but the investigation into Janet's murder continued round the clock. By July, five months had passed and investigators still weren't any closer to
希望学院为珍妮特·钱德勒举行了追悼会，学校校长在会上评论道：“像这样的事件触动了我们最深处的思想和情感。为什么的问题充斥着我们的头脑，却没有现成或令人满意的答案，任何人能说的话都很少。我们相信上帝会在这段时间给予珍妮特的家人和她所有的朋友一份特别的恩典和力量。”珍妮特被谋杀两周后，切姆特隆油漆厂的罢工终于结束，瓦肯胡特安保人员散回了他们的家乡。荷兰市周围的事情平静了下来，但对珍妮特谋杀案的调查仍在全天候进行。到七月，五个月过去了，调查人员仍然没有更接近
solving the case. The task force, which at one point had 20 people, was now ever seen by a team of just four. The reward for information was bolstered to $3,000 in an attempt to boost the dwindling tips that were coming through. Police questioned and re-interviewed Janet's friends, family members and co-workers, as well as people who were staying at the Blue Mill Inn at the time of the murder. There was nothing to suggest who could have targeted Janet or why. Her best friend and roommate, Laurie Swank, who was a manager at the motel, hadn't been working on the night of the attack. Laurie couldn't think of any guests who would want to harm Janet. Around half a dozen persons of interest emerged during the course of the investigation,
解决此案。曾经有20人的专案组现在由仅四人的团队监督。悬赏信息被提高到3000美元，试图增加不断减少的举报。警方询问并重新采访了珍妮特的朋友、家人和同事，以及谋杀发生时住在蓝磨坊旅馆的人。没有任何迹象表明谁可能针对珍妮特或原因。她的好友兼室友劳里·斯旺是旅馆的经理，在袭击发生的那晚没有上班。劳里想不出任何想伤害珍妮特的客人。在调查过程中，出现了大约半打相关人员，
some of whom were subject to polygraph testing, but none were concrete suspects and there wasn't enough evidence to make any arrests. Police continued to follow every lead, but came to nothing but dead ends. Despite amassing more than 1,000 pages of notes, the identity of Janet's killer remained a mystery. The case was reluctantly shelved, but members of the Holland Police Department refused to let it go entirely. A photo of Janet was pinned to a communal bulletin board, so they would never forget. 12 years later, in August of 1991, a 34-year-old vagrant named Donald Leroy Evans was detained in Colorado on suspicion of raping and murdering a 10-year-old Mississippi girl named Beatrice Ruth. Upon his arrest, Evans not only confessed to this crime, but he also made a
其中一些人接受了测谎测试，但没有一个是具体的嫌疑人，也没有足够的证据进行任何逮捕。警方继续追踪每一条线索，但最终都走进了死胡同。尽管积累了1000多页的笔记，珍妮特杀手的身份仍然是一个谜。此案被勉强搁置，但荷兰警察局的成员拒绝完全放弃。珍妮特的一张照片被钉在公共公告栏上，这样他们就永远不会忘记。12年后，即1991年8月，一名34岁的流浪汉唐纳德·勒罗伊·埃文斯在科罗拉多州被拘留，涉嫌强奸并谋杀了一名10岁的密西西比女孩比阿特丽斯·鲁斯。被捕后，埃文斯不仅承认了这起罪行，他还做出了一个
shocking revelation. He admitted to having killed up to 70 people across 22 American states over the course of a decade. Most of his victims were taken from road stops or public parks. Police were dubious about Evans' claims. It wasn't unusual for killers to confess to crimes they didn't commit, and Evans had no evidence to back his stories. In addition, he claimed most of his professor victims were either homeless or involved in sex work, which made it difficult for police to investigate. That was until Evans claimed responsibility for two unsolved murders that took place in Florida in 1985. Regarding the deaths of 38-year-olds Ira Jean Smith and Janet Movic, he provided details that only the killer could possibly know. Evans claims that he was a
令人震惊的披露。他承认在十年间在22个美国州杀害了多达70人。他的大多数受害者都是从路边或公园带走的。警方对埃文斯的说法持怀疑态度。杀手承认他们没有犯下的罪行并不罕见，而且埃文斯没有证据支持他的故事。此外，他声称他大多数受害者要么是无家可归者，要么从事性工作，这使得警方很难调查。直到埃文斯声称对1985年在佛罗里达州发生的两起未破谋杀案负责。关于38岁的艾拉·简·史密斯和珍妮特·莫维克的死亡，他提供了只有杀手才可能知道的细节。埃文斯声称他是一个
prolific serial killer didn't seem quite as questionable. A special FBI task force was established to sift through hundreds of unsolved murders across the United States to determine if Donald Evans could be a potential suspect. Janet Chandler's case was amongst the files. Evans was a drifter who moved constantly from state to state, and it was soon revealed that in 1981, he lived at three different addresses in Holland, Michigan. For Holland police, this was the best lead they'd uncovered since Janet's murder 12 years earlier. Yet, a further dive into Evans' history failed to uncover any information that placed him in Holland in January 1979. What had initially seemed like a promising league was yet another in a series
多产的连环杀手似乎并不那么令人怀疑。一个特别的联邦调查局专案组成立，旨在筛选美国各地数百起未破谋杀案，以确定唐纳德·埃文斯是否可能是潜在嫌疑人。珍妮特·钱德勒的案件就在档案中。埃文斯是一个不断从一个州搬到另一个州的流浪者，很快发现他在1981年住在密歇根州荷兰市的三个不同地址。对于荷兰警方来说，这是他们自12年前珍妮特被谋杀以来发现的最好线索。然而，对埃文斯历史的进一步挖掘未能发现任何将他置于1979年1月荷兰市的信息。最初看起来像是一个有希望的线索，结果却是一系列
of dead ends. Hope College Associate Professor David Shock liked to keep things interesting for his communication students. With a background in journalism, he thought it would be useful for his pupils to learn how to establish good relationships with law enforcement. In 2003, Professor Shock organized for his class of eight students to meet with a detective from the Holland Police Department, a 30-year veteran of the force who was about to retire. During the meeting, the professor asked the detective if there was one case that he wished could be solved. The detective didn't hesitate. He pointed to the photo of Janet Chandler that had remained pinned to the police bulletin board for over 20 years and said, the Chandler case.
死胡同中的又一个。希望学院副教授大卫·肖克喜欢让他的传播学学生保持兴趣。凭借新闻背景，他认为让学生学习如何与执法部门建立良好的关系很有用。2003年，肖克教授组织他的八名学生班级与荷兰警察局的一名侦探会面，这是一位即将退休的30年警队老兵。在会议期间，教授问侦探是否有一个他希望能够解决的案件。侦探没有犹豫。他指着钉在警察公告栏上20多年的珍妮特·钱德勒的照片说：“钱德勒案。”
Professor Shock's interest was immediately peaked. An idea started churning in his head. What if his students made a film about Janet Chandler's life, not necessarily with the aim of solving the case, but as a means to keep her memory alive? They could speak to Janet's loved ones and people who worked on the case. At the very best, it might uncover some new leads, and if not, it would still be a fascinating educational tool for his students that would also pay tribute to a young life tragically lost. The project was given the green light, and with only four months to get the documentary done, Professor Shock's students quickly got to work scheduling interviews.
肖克教授的兴趣立即被激发了。一个想法开始在他的脑海中翻腾。如果他的学生制作一部关于珍妮特·钱德勒生活的电影，不一定是为了解决案件，而是作为一种让她的记忆鲜活的方式呢？他们可以与珍妮特的亲人以及处理此案的人交谈。最好的情况是，它可能会发现一些新的线索，如果不能，它仍然是一个引人入胜的教育工具，也将向一个悲剧性失去的年轻生命致敬。该项目获得了批准，只有四个月的时间来完成纪录片，肖克教授的学生们迅速开始安排采访。
21-year-old Sarah Hartman was apprehensive. Although she was excited about being involved with the film, the prospect of interviewing a murder victim's parents unnerved her. But as she sat down across from Jim and Glenna Chandler at their home, her anxiety quickly dissipated. The elderly couple were warm and approachable, despite their obvious nerves. They spoke lovingly about their daughter, reliving fond memories, like the time their neighbours gathered outside their window to hear Janet sing. They reminisced about her beautiful voice, her dedication to Christ, and her habit of underlining significant passages in the Bible.
21岁的莎拉·哈特曼感到忐忑不安。虽然她对参与这部电影感到兴奋，但采访谋杀案受害者父母的前景让她感到不安。但当她坐在吉姆和格伦娜·钱德勒家中对面时，她的焦虑很快消散了。这对年迈的夫妇虽然明显紧张，但热情且平易近人。他们深情地谈论着他们的女儿，重温美好的回忆，比如邻居们聚集在窗外听珍妮特唱歌的时候。他们回忆起她美丽的嗓音、她对基督的奉献，以及她在圣经中划出重要段落的习惯。
Despite 24 years passing since Janet's murder, the Chandler's grief was still immense. Now in their golden years, it pained the couple to think they could die without their daughter's killer ever being brought to justice. Glenna said, A parent never expects their children to go before them. You learn to live with it. That's about all you can do. One day at a time. It didn't take long for Professor Shock's students to become personally invested in Janet's case. Collectively, they spent hundreds of hours researching everything they could about the crime and interviewing everyone from Janet's former music teachers
尽管珍妮特被谋杀已经过去了24年，但钱德勒夫妇的悲伤依然巨大。现在已步入晚年的他们，想到自己可能会在女儿的杀手被绳之以法之前死去，这让他们感到痛苦。格伦娜说：“父母从不期望孩子走在他们前面。你学会了与它共存。这就是你能做的全部。过一天算一天。”肖克教授的学生们没过多久就个人投入到了珍妮特的案件中。总的来说，他们花费了数百小时研究关于犯罪的一切，并采访了从珍妮特的音乐老师
to detectives who had attended the Blue Mill Inn on the night of Janet's abduction. The more they found out, the more committed they became to discovering the truth. One thing was abundantly clear. Everyone who worked on the case had a different theory about what happened on that night back in 1979. One investigator believed Janet had fallen victim to a serial killer. Another thought they knew who was responsible, but didn't have the evidence to prove it, and that person had since passed away. They believed the killer didn't act alone, but up to three individuals could have been involved. The takeaway message seemed to be that Janet's case would likely never be solved,
到珍妮特被绑架那晚在蓝磨坊旅馆值班的侦探等所有人。他们发现的越多，就越致力于发现真相。有一件事非常清楚。每个处理此案的人对1979年那晚发生的事情都有不同的理论。一位调查员认为珍妮特是连环杀手的受害者。另一位认为他们知道谁负责，但没有证据证明，而那个人已经去世了。他们认为杀手不是单独行动，可能有多达三个人参与。结论似乎是，珍妮特的案件可能永远不会被解决，
regardless of how many people wanted closure. The only thing that could propel the investigation forward would be the emergence of new evidence. When the documentary, which was titled Who Killed Janet Chandler, screened at the Nicaragua Theater on January 30, 2004, Holland police chief John Krytov was completely enthralled. He had been a young member of the Holland police force at the time of Janet's murder, and like so many other officers, the case continued to haunt him. Krytov had been thinking about it more and more ever since the Hope College students started poking around, and now, seeing Janet's loved ones talk on the big screen about their need for justice, he felt even more compelled to do something. Krytov made contact with Michigan
无论有多少人想要结案。唯一能推动调查前进的事情将是新证据的出现。当名为《谁杀了珍妮特·钱德勒》的纪录片于2004年1月30日在尼加拉瓜剧院放映时，荷兰警察局长约翰·克里托夫完全被吸引住了。他在珍妮特被谋杀时是荷兰警队的一名年轻成员，像许多其他警官一样，这个案件继续困扰着他。自从希望学院的学生开始四处打听以来，克里托夫一直在更多地思考它，现在，看到珍妮特的亲人在大银幕上谈论他们对正义的需求，他感到更有动力去做点什么。克里托夫与密歇根州
State Police, who held jurisdiction over Janet's case. They agreed that the murder was worth re-investigating, and who better to take the lead than Detective David Van Lopik, a veteran of the force who had been raised in Holland and remembered Janet's murder well. In April 2004, a task force led by Van Lopik was officially formed, with three officers from Michigan State Police and the Holland Police Department committed to solving Janet's case once and for all. This time, the investigators were determined not to leave any stone unturned. Despite the huge advances in technology since Janet's murder, they had no DNA or fingerprints to go on, leaving them to rely on good old-fashioned police work. They gathered all of the original
州警察取得了联系，他们对珍妮特的案件拥有管辖权。他们同意这起谋杀案值得重新调查，还有谁比大卫·范洛皮克侦探更适合带头呢？他是一位在荷兰市长大并对珍妮特谋杀案记忆犹新的警队老兵。2004年4月，由范洛皮克领导的专案组正式成立，三名来自密歇根州警察局和荷兰警察局的警官致力于彻底解决珍妮特的案件。这一次，调查人员决心不遗余力。尽管自珍妮特被谋杀以来技术取得了巨大进步，但他们没有DNA或指纹可循，只能依靠老派的警察工作。他们收集了所有原始
case notes and decided to start in Holland, then work their way outwards, starting with the Janet Chandler herself. The documentary had painted a rosy picture of Janet's life, but it had barely scratched the surface. If the detectives could learn more about who Janet was away from her family and teachers, perhaps they'd uncover a detail that could lead to a clue. As cold case member, Lieutenant John Slank remarked, The more we get to know about the victim, the more we understand the victim. The victim will oftentimes, even in death, point us to their killer or killers. Using the documentary to spark people's memories, the investigators hoped that the passing of time,
案件笔记，并决定从荷兰市开始，然后向外扩展，从珍妮特·钱德勒本人开始。纪录片描绘了珍妮特生活的美好图景，但几乎没有触及表面。如果侦探们能更多地了解珍妮特在家人和老师之外是谁，也许他们会发现一个可能导致线索的细节。正如冷案组成员约翰·斯兰克中尉所说：“我们对受害者了解得越多，我们就越了解受害者。受害者往往，即使在死后，也会指引我们找到他们的杀手。”利用纪录片激发人们的记忆，调查人员希望时间的流逝、
distance and circumstance would encourage someone to talk. They began talking to people who had moved in the same social circles as Janet and discovered that shortly after she'd first enrolled in college, something happened that shook her entire belief system. Janet had been seduced by an older man. While she'd always viewed premarital sex as a mortal sin, the middle-aged man soon convinced Janet to sleep with him. Before long, they were meeting at her parents' house on a regular basis to have sex. Their relationship went on for over a year, but Janet's parents never found out about it.
距离和环境会鼓励某人开口。他们开始与那些与珍妮特在同一个社交圈的人交谈，发现她在刚入学不久后，发生了一件动摇她整个信仰体系的事情。珍妮特被一个年长的男人诱惑了。虽然她一直认为婚前性行为是死罪，但那个中年男人很快说服了珍妮特与他发生关系。不久之后，他们经常在珍妮特父母家见面发生性关系。他们的关系持续了一年多，但珍妮特的父母从未发现。
According to one of Janet's childhood friends, the relationship had a huge impact on her religious beliefs. Janet realized she could sin without being punished for it. Suddenly, her world started to open up. She began experimenting with alcohol, cannabis and dating, stepping outside the boundaries that she'd strived so hard to follow. With investigators now having a clearer picture, they were keen to speak to the person who likely knew her best around that period. Her best friend and roommate, Lori Swank. Lori had left Holland shortly after Janet's murder and hadn't maintained contact with many people there since. She was now working as a nursing assistant 630 miles east in the small
据珍妮特的一位童年朋友说，这段关系对她的宗教信仰产生了巨大的影响。珍妮特意识到她可以犯罪而不受惩罚。突然，她的世界开始打开。她开始尝试酒精、大麻和约会，走出了她努力遵循的界限。随着调查人员现在有了更清晰的图景，他们渴望与那个时期可能最了解她的人交谈。她的好友兼室友劳里·斯旺。劳里在珍妮特被谋杀后不久就离开了荷兰市，此后与那里的许多人没有保持联系。她现在在630英里外的东部小镇担任护理助理
borough of Nescapec, Pennsylvania, when detectives surprised her with a visit. Lori fondly remembered Janet as a fun-loving musician, but when pressed, she admitted there was more to her than met the eye. When the two friends were working at the Blue Mill Inn, they'd gotten into their share of mischief. Lori divulged that both she and Janet had been having sexual relations with several of the Wackenhart security guards, whom she described as a wild group who liked to party. Things had sometimes gotten a bit out of hand. On one occasion, Janet had summoned one of the guards to the front desk. When he came down, she was waiting for him in an adjacent display suite wearing nothing but
宾夕法尼亚州的内斯卡佩克，当时侦探们突然拜访了她。劳里深情地记得珍妮特是一位热爱生活的音乐家，但当被追问时，她承认她比表面看起来更复杂。当两个朋友在蓝磨坊旅馆工作时，她们也参与了一些恶作剧。劳里透露，她和珍妮特都与几名瓦肯胡特安保人员发生了性关系，她形容他们是一群喜欢聚会的狂野群体。事情有时会有点失控。有一次，珍妮特叫了一名保安到前台。当他下来时，她穿着除了
a pair of cowboy boots. Lori, who was technically Janet's boss, had no choice but to give Janet a stern talking to. As far as she knew, Lori hadn't seen or heard anything that could help with the investigation. She said Janet didn't deserve what happened to her and that the whole situation made her feel physically sick. Quote, How can you live with yourself having knowledge of that? How can you live with it? I couldn't. The more people detectives questioned, the clearer it became that the Blue Mill Inn had been a hotspot for partying. One investigator described it as a, quote, den of iniquity, a place where the guests and staff could drink, take drugs and have sex without
一双牛仔靴外什么都没穿，在隔壁的展示套房里等着他。劳里在技术上是珍妮特的上司，别无选择，只能严厉地训斥珍妮特。据她所知，劳里没有看到或听到任何可以帮助调查的事情。她说珍妮特不应该遭受那种待遇，整个情况让她感到身体不适。引用：“知道这些事，你怎么能过得去？你怎么能忍受？我不能。”侦探们询问的人越多，蓝磨坊旅馆是聚会热点就越清楚。一位调查员将其描述为“罪恶之窝”，一个客人和员工可以喝酒、吸毒和发生性关系而没有任何
any supervision. Therefore, it made sense to assume that the crime could have been committed by someone with a connection to the motel. Investigators compiled a list of all the guests who were staying at the Blue Mill at the time of Janet's murder. The majority had been Wackenhart security guards. Because the strike ended shortly after Janet was killed, many of the guards left town without ever being questioned by police. Tracking them down 25 years later wasn't an easy task. Most had lived transient lifestyles, moving from one job to the next across towns and states. The investigative team began traveling the country to question those of interest. Time and time again, the response was the same. Most of the guards said they barely
监督的地方。因此，假设犯罪可能是由与旅馆有联系的人犯下的，这是合理的。调查人员编制了一份珍妮特被谋杀时住在蓝磨坊的所有客人的名单。大多数是瓦肯胡特安保人员。因为罢工在珍妮特被杀后不久就结束了，许多保安在没有受到警方询问的情况下就离开了城镇。25年后追踪他们并不是一件容易的事。大多数人过着漂泊的生活方式，从一个城镇和州搬到另一个城镇和州。调查小组开始在全国各地旅行以询问相关人员。一次又一次，回答是一样的。大多数保安说他们几乎
remembered Janet Chandler. Their time in Holland had been consumed by work. After gruelling 12-hour shifts, they retired to the Blue Mill Inn to eat and sleep before doing it all again the following day. On their rare breaks, they blew off steam in the dive bar next door or through parties in one another's rooms. The former guards were shown the Who Killed Janet Chandler documentary in the hopes it might jog old memories, but nobody knew anything about Janet's murder or had any information that could help with the investigation. That was until Harry Keith watched the film. Harry had worked as a security guard for Wackenhart, but he'd also been a keen photographer. During his stay at the Blue Mill Inn,
不记得珍妮特·钱德勒了。他们在荷兰市的时间被工作占据了。在艰苦的12小时轮班后，他们回到蓝磨坊旅馆吃饭和睡觉，第二天再做一遍。在难得的休息时间，他们通过隔壁的潜水酒吧或在彼此的房间里聚会来放松。前保安们观看了《谁杀了珍妮特·钱德勒》纪录片，希望能唤起旧记忆，但没有人知道关于珍妮特谋杀案的任何事情，也没有任何可以帮助调查的信息。直到哈里·基思看了这部电影。哈里曾作为瓦肯胡特的一名保安工作，但他也是一名热心的摄影师。在蓝磨坊旅馆逗留期间，
he'd taken his camera out on several occasions. Watching the documentary, an emotional Harry recognized one of the photos of Janet as one that he'd taken. And it wasn't the only one. Harry retrieved an old photo album. Inside were pages of photographs taken back during the Chemtron strike in 1979. They featured the wild alcohol-fueled parties that the investigators had been hearing about. In one photo, Janet sat on a guard's lap with a drinking hand wearing a guard's uniform. There was one guard who featured in several of the photographs and particularly caught investigators' eyes. During their questioning, a former Wackenhart employee had revealed they'd heard an unsubstantiated rumor that this individual might have been
他曾多次带着相机外出。在观看这部纪录片时，哈里激动地认出珍妮特照片中的一张是他拍的。而且不止这一张。哈里找出了一个旧相册。里面有1979年切姆特隆（Chemtron）罢工期间拍摄的照片。照片中记录了调查人员一直听说的那些酒精泛滥的狂野派对。在一张照片中，珍妮特坐在一名穿着保安制服的男子的腿上，手里拿着酒。其中一名保安出现在多张照片中，特别引起了调查人员的注意。在审讯过程中，一名Wackenhart的前员工透露，他们曾听到一个未经证实的传言，称此人可能
involved in Janet's murder. That man was Robert Lynch, the guest who had called 911 to report a robbery taking place at the Blue Mill Inn, the night Janet was abducted. Robert Lynch had been nearing 40 during his time in Holland, making him one of the oldest Wackenhart security guards. Due to his age, he felt like a bit of an outsider and wasn't part of the hard partying crew. He'd since married and had two children, leaving the security game behind to open a beauty school with his wife. Detectives tracked Lynch down to the small Michigan town of Three Oaks, 80 miles south of Holland. By this point, the investigation had been reopened for an entire year and they were no closer to solving the case. They had no reason to believe the now
与珍妮特的谋杀案有关。那个人就是罗伯特·林奇（Robert Lynch），也就是珍妮特被绑架当晚打电话报警称蓝磨坊旅馆（Blue Mill Inn）发生抢劫案的客人。罗伯特·林奇在荷兰（Holland）工作期间已近40岁，是Wackenhart最年长的保安之一。由于年龄原因，他觉得自己有点格格不入，并没有参与那些疯狂的派对。此后他结了婚，有了两个孩子，离开了安保行业，与妻子开了一家美容学校。侦探们在距离荷兰以南80英里的密歇根州三橡树镇（Three Oaks）找到了林奇。此时，案件已经重启整整一年，但他们离破案仍毫无进展。他们没有理由相信现在的
65-year-old Lynch was involved in Janet's murder, but Harry Keith's photos revealed the two definitely knew one another. Furthermore, upon re-listening to the audio of Lynch's 911 call, detectives had some new questions. Despite reporting what he suspected to be a robbery in progress, Lynch's voice sounded curiously emotionless. Was it possible the call was staged? If Robert Lynch knew anything about Janet's murder, he wasn't talking. He gave evasive answers, telling detectives he had very little memory of his time in Holland. This was credible, given that he had a serious drinking problem. With no evidence tying him to the crime, it was back to the drawing board. But the cold case team wasn't prepared to rule Robert Lynch out
65岁的林奇与珍妮特的谋杀案有关，但哈里·基思（Harry Keith）的照片显示，两人确实认识。此外，在重新听取林奇的报警录音时，侦探们产生了一些新的疑问。尽管林奇报告称他怀疑发生了抢劫，但他的声音听起来却异常冷漠。这通电话有可能是伪造的吗？如果罗伯特·林奇知道关于珍妮特谋杀案的任何内情，他并没有说出来。他回答得含糊其辞，告诉侦探他对在荷兰的那段时光记忆模糊。考虑到他有严重的酗酒问题，这一点倒是可信。由于没有证据将他与犯罪联系起来，调查又回到了原点。但冷案组并不打算将罗伯特·林奇
completely. Even though they continued questioning other persons of interest and chasing up the smallest of leads, as the months passed by, they kept returning to Lynch. Maybe it was just a hunch, but they couldn't shake the feeling that he knew more than he was letting on. Lynch was questioned several more times, always maintaining that he had no knowledge of Janet's murder. Detectives weren't quite sure how to take him. On the surface, he appeared to be a committed family man with no serious criminal record. But his drinking habits suggested a man who was trying to drown some kind of sorrow. The detectives hoped that if they continued pressing him, some cracks would begin to show. In June 2005, Robert Lynch finally admitted that he and
完全排除。尽管他们继续盘问其他相关人员并追查哪怕最微小的线索，但随着时间的推移，他们总是回到林奇身上。也许这只是直觉，但他们无法摆脱一种感觉，即他知道的比他透露的要多。林奇又被审问了几次，始终坚称他对珍妮特的谋杀案一无所知。侦探们不太确定该如何对待他。表面上看，他似乎是一个顾家的男人，没有严重的犯罪记录。但他的酗酒习惯暗示着一个试图用酒精来淹没某种悲伤的人。侦探们希望如果继续向他施压，他会露出马脚。2005年6月，罗伯特·林奇终于承认他和
Janet had been intimately involved, despite him being 17 years her senior. The two had sexual relations at the Blue Mill Inn and also met for a rendezvous at a vacant house. That wasn't all. Around the time that Janet was killed, Lynch heard that she'd attended a party with some of the other security guards that, quote, went haywire. He claimed not to know anything else about it, but for the cold case team, this was a huge revelation. After all these years and all the people they'd questioned, this was the very first they had heard about such a party. Still convinced that Lynch knew more than he was letting on, lead detective David Venlopik returned to question him just over a week later. Lynch was in a somber, reflective mood.
珍妮特曾有过亲密关系，尽管他比她大17岁。两人在蓝磨坊旅馆发生过性关系，也曾在空房子里幽会。不仅如此。在珍妮特遇害前后，林奇听说她曾和其他一些保安参加过一个“失控”的派对。他声称对此一无所知，但对于冷案组来说，这是一个巨大的发现。这么多年来，在他们盘问过的所有人中，这是他们第一次听说有这样的派对。首席侦探大卫·文洛皮克（David Venlopik）仍然确信林奇知道的比他透露的要多，于是一周多后又回来审问他。林奇当时情绪低落，陷入沉思。
He began speaking about the death of his father before suddenly blurting out. I regret my whole life. Some of the things I've done I don't even want to talk about. Detective Venlopik recognized this was an important moment. He asked Lynch if the reason he drank was to forget. Lynch replied, I'm running from everything. After that, he went quiet. It felt like the breakthrough the investigators were waiting for was close, but just out of reach. Maybe Lynch needed more time. Three months later, Detective Venlopik returned to Three Oaks to interview Lynch yet again. He was accompanied by his partner, Detective Jeffrey Floor, who specialized in interrogation
他开始谈论他父亲的去世，然后突然脱口而出：“我后悔我的一生。我做过的一些事情，我甚至不想谈论。”侦探文洛皮克意识到这是一个重要的时刻。他问林奇，他喝酒是否是为了遗忘。林奇回答说：“我在逃避一切。”此后，他沉默了。感觉调查人员等待的突破口近在咫尺，却又遥不可及。也许林奇需要更多时间。三个月后，侦探文洛皮克回到三橡树镇再次采访林奇。陪同他的是他的搭档，专门负责审讯的杰弗里·弗洛尔（Jeffrey Floor）侦探，
and was known for his ability to break suspects. This time, Venlopik brought his secret weapon, a copy of the documentary Who Killed Janet Chandler. The detectives put the DVD in and pressed play. When it came to a part where Janet's father was shown fighting back tears, Detective Floor hit pause, turned to Robert Lynch and asked, you have children, right? You remember the first time you went somewhere with them and you just lost them. You remember that feeling you got inside your body. Now imagine, just imagine what that would feel like when you're talking about a 22 year old girl. You have a daughter, Janet's age. If she were killed, wouldn't you want to know what happened to her?
他以能够击垮嫌疑人而闻名。这一次，文洛皮克带来了他的秘密武器——纪录片《谁杀了珍妮特·钱德勒》（Who Killed Janet Chandler）的拷贝。侦探们放入DVD并按下播放键。当画面播放到珍妮特的父亲强忍泪水时，弗洛尔侦探按下了暂停，转向罗伯特·林奇问道：“你有孩子，对吧？你还记得第一次带他们去某个地方却把他们弄丢的时候吗？你还记得当时你身体里的那种感觉吗？现在想象一下，试着想象一下，当你谈论一个22岁的女孩时，那会是什么感觉。你有一个和珍妮特年纪相仿的女儿。如果她被杀了，难道你不想知道她发生了什么事吗？”
Lynch's eyes welled with tears. His lip quivered. It took four months and a total of 18 interrogation sessions, before Lynch finally admitted exactly what he meant when he said Janet had attended a party that went haywire. Just before 2am on Wednesday, January 31, 1979, Lynch and another security guard named James Nelson, who went by the nickname Baba, made their way down into the front lobby of the Blue Mill Inn. Janet was working behind the desk. Nelson had some exciting news. A surprise party was being held in Janet's honour. It was taking place at the residence of Arthur Piver, the head
林奇的眼眶湿润了，嘴唇颤抖。经过四个月、总共18次审讯，林奇终于承认了他所说的“珍妮特参加了一个失控的派对”到底是什么意思。1979年1月31日星期三凌晨2点前，林奇和另一名绰号叫“巴巴”（Baba）的保安詹姆斯·尼尔森（James Nelson）来到蓝磨坊旅馆的前台。珍妮特正在柜台后工作。尼尔森带来了一个令人兴奋的消息：有人要为珍妮特举办一个惊喜派对。派对地点在亚瑟·皮弗（Arthur Piver）的住所，他是
security guard who was living in a guest house on the grounds of the Camtron paint plant. Janet stepped out from behind the desk and the two security guards pinned her arms behind her back and placed her in handcuffs. According to Lynch, Janet had no problem with this. She believed their story about the surprise party and allowed the men to blindfold her by duck-taping gores over her eyes. It was Lynch himself who came up with the idea to stage a robbery. With the Janet unable to see, they quickly pocketed cash from behind the front desk and the adjoining office so that it would look like the motel had been robbed. Nelson then walked to Janet to a waiting car outside. Several other Wackenhart security guards and a group of female motel
住在切姆特隆油漆厂场地内客房的保安主管。珍妮特从柜台后面走出来，两名保安将她的双臂反剪在身后，给她戴上了手铐。据林奇说，珍妮特对此并无异议。她相信了他们关于惊喜派对的说法，并允许他们用胶带蒙住她的眼睛。正是林奇本人想出了伪造抢劫案的主意。在珍妮特看不见的情况下，他们迅速从前台和隔壁办公室拿走了现金，让现场看起来像是旅馆被抢劫了。随后，尼尔森将珍妮特带到外面等候的汽车上。其他几名Wackenhart保安和一群旅馆女员工
employees were standing on a balcony overlooking the front lobby. As Janet was whisked away, they watched with full awareness of the plan that was about to unfold. With the Janet safely off the premises, Lynch called 911 and made the false report about overhearing a robbery taking place. When the police arrived, he told them that the front desk clerk was nowhere to be seen. Needing a few hours of sleep before his shift at Camtron started in the morning, Lynch then went back to his room and went to bed. Exactly what happened to Janet at Arthur Piver's guesthouse in the hours that followed
站在俯瞰前台大厅的阳台上。当珍妮特被带走时，他们完全清楚即将展开的计划。在珍妮特安全离开现场后，林奇拨打了911，谎报称听到发生了抢劫。当警察赶到时，他告诉他们前台接待员不见了。由于在早上开始切姆特隆的轮班前需要睡几个小时，林奇随后回到房间睡觉。在接下来的几个小时里，珍妮特在亚瑟·皮弗的客房里到底发生了什么，
remains unclear. The following day, Lynch worked his shift as though nothing had happened. It was his job to pay employees their daily allowances while also taking care of other clerical duties. After clocking off at around 6pm, he quickly freshened up, then made his way to Arthur Piver's place. Approximately 15 to 20 other guests were already there, six of whom were women. Janet Chandler was among them. She had been stripped naked and was sitting on a couch, her eyes glazed over as though she'd been drugged. Her hands were bound in front of her, and her mouth was sealed with duct tape while the party continued around her.
仍然不清楚。第二天，林奇照常上班，仿佛什么都没发生过。他的工作是向员工发放每日津贴，并处理其他文书工作。下午6点左右下班后，他迅速梳洗一番，然后前往亚瑟·皮弗的住处。大约有15到20名其他客人在那里，其中6名是女性。珍妮特·钱德勒也在其中。她被剥光了衣服，坐在沙发上，眼神呆滞，仿佛被下了药。她的双手被绑在身前，嘴巴被胶带封住，而派对在她周围继续进行。
Music played as several partygoers drank and smoked cannabis, and one of the security guards danced around in his underwear. A docile Janet Chandler was paraded around the room as the other attendees heckled and shamed her. Robert Lynch watched on with drink in hand, as a mutual understanding filtered through the crowd. It was time to continue the humiliation. One of the other attendees, a Wackenhardt guard named Freddy Parker, fastened his belt around Janet's neck and led her to an upstairs bedroom. Several of the guards followed and lined up at the bedroom door. Lynch was one of them.
音乐响起，一些参加派对的人喝酒吸食大麻，一名保安穿着内裤跳舞。温顺的珍妮特·钱德勒被带到房间里游行，其他参加者对她进行嘲讽和羞辱。罗伯特·林奇手里拿着酒杯看着，一种共识在人群中蔓延开来。是时候继续羞辱她了。另一名参加者，一名叫弗雷迪·帕克（Freddy Parker）的Wackenhart保安，将他的皮带系在珍妮特的脖子上，把她带到了楼上的卧室。几名保安跟在后面，在卧室门口排队。林奇就是其中之一。
The group threw Janet onto the bed and blindfolded her with duct tape. One by one, they took turns raping her. Freddy Parker kept watch at the door, deciding who was permitted to enter. After Piver had the last say on who was allowed to participate. As Piver assaulted Janet, he yanked on the belt and shouted, You're going to die, bitch. You're going to die. James Nelson, Robert Lynch and Freddy Parker followed his lead, each raping and choking Janet with the belt until she was barely conscious.
这群人把珍妮特扔到床上，用胶带蒙住她的眼睛。他们一个接一个地轮奸了她。弗雷迪·帕克在门口把守，决定谁可以进入。皮弗对谁可以参与有最终决定权。当皮弗侵犯珍妮特时，他猛拉皮带并大喊：“你去死吧，婊子。你去死吧。”詹姆斯·尼尔森、罗伯特·林奇和弗雷迪·帕克效仿他的做法，每个人都轮流强奸并用皮带勒住珍妮特，直到她几乎失去知觉。
While all of this was taking place, no other guests at the party did anything to intervene. In fact, they encouraged it. One of Janet's female friends was amongst them, but Lynch couldn't remember her name. As she watched the guards assault and beat Janet, her friend looked directly at her and said, You bitch. Eventually, after all the men were done, Robert Lynch got on top of Janet and used his knees to pin her down on the bed. He punched her, bit her on the neck, and then tightened his hold on the belt until Janet stopped moving. When it was clear she was no longer breathing, he ripped the duct tape off her eyes. The room erupted into panic.
在这一切发生时，派对上的其他客人都没有采取任何干预措施。事实上，他们还鼓励这样做。珍妮特的一位女性朋友也在其中，但林奇记不起她的名字了。当她看着保安们殴打和虐待珍妮特时，她的朋友直视着她说：“你这个婊子。”最终，在所有男人都完事后，罗伯特·林奇爬到珍妮特身上，用膝盖把她压在床上。他打了她，咬了她的脖子，然后收紧了皮带，直到珍妮特停止了挣扎。当确定她不再呼吸时，他撕掉了她眼睛上的胶带。房间里爆发出一阵恐慌。
After Piver threw a chair against the wall and yelled, the fucking party is over. Aware of what had just happened in the upstairs bedroom, most of the party goers pitched in to help clean up the crime scene. They knew police were on the hunt for Janet, and they had to get rid of her body, fast. Janet's binds were removed. Then several of the guards washed her down, before Lynch and Williams wrapped her up in a sheet and bundled her into a car. Under the cover of darkness, Lynch hit the snowy roads and drove nearly 40 miles south. Eventually, he pulled over on the 196 highway and dragged Janet's body off towards a snow bank.
在皮弗把一把椅子砸在墙上并大喊“该死的派对结束了”之后。意识到楼上卧室刚刚发生的事情，大多数参加派对的人都帮忙清理犯罪现场。他们知道警察正在搜寻珍妮特，他们必须尽快处理掉她的尸体。珍妮特的束缚被解开了。然后几名保安给她清洗了一下，林奇和威廉姆斯用床单把她裹起来，塞进了一辆车里。在夜色的掩护下，林奇驱车驶上积雪的道路，向南行驶了近40英里。最终，他在196号高速公路上靠边停车，将珍妮特的尸体拖向一个雪堆。
Two weeks later, the chemtron strike ended and the Wacken hut security guards were no longer needed. The men left town, vowing never to speak about what had happened during their time in Holland. They allegedly operated under a code of silence, maintaining the unofficial Wacken hut company motto, I know nothing, I see nothing, I speak only in kind words. Many of their paths never crossed again, but Lynch's involvement with the Janet's murder followed him wherever he went. He turned to the bottle, desperately trying to erase the night from his memory. With the truth about what happened to Janet finally revealed,
两周后，切姆特隆罢工结束，Wackenhart保安不再被需要。这些人离开了小镇，发誓永远不谈论他们在荷兰期间发生的事情。据称，他们在一个沉默准则下运作，维持着Wackenhart公司非官方的座右铭：“我什么都不知道，我什么都没看见，我只说好话。”他们的许多人此后再也没有交集，但林奇参与珍妮特的谋杀案却如影随形。他转向酒精，拼命试图从记忆中抹去那个夜晚。随着珍妮特遇害真相的最终揭露，
one huge question remained. Why? What motivated this group of individuals to intentionally take Janet's life in the most brutal way possible? Lynch initially claimed he couldn't remember the name of Janet's friend who had witnessed and encouraged the attack. But as he was pressed further, he recalled her first name, Laurie. Armed with Lynch's confession, the detectives confronted Laurie Swank again. They were at a loss as to why Janet's supposed best friend would not only watch as Janet was viciously raped, but apparently encouraged. Swank continued to deny any knowledge of Janet's murder. Detective Jeffrey Floor gradually turned up the heat, stating,
一个巨大的问题仍然存在。为什么？是什么动机促使这群人以最残忍的方式故意夺走珍妮特的生命？林奇最初声称他不记得那个目睹并鼓励袭击的珍妮特朋友的名字。但在进一步施压下，他想起了她的名字叫劳里（Laurie）。掌握了林奇的供词后，侦探们再次与劳里·斯旺克（Laurie Swank）对质。他们不明白为什么珍妮特所谓的最好的朋友不仅看着珍妮特被残忍强奸，而且显然还给予了鼓励。斯旺克继续否认对珍妮特的谋杀案有任何了解。杰弗里·弗洛尔侦探逐渐加强了攻势，说道：
You saw Lynch kill her, didn't you? Just tell the truth. Give up the battle. Just give up the battle and tell me you saw it. You were there when she died, weren't you? That's why you ran. No longer able to hide the truth, Swank finally broke, admitting that she'd been part of the plan all along. It all started when Janet began sleeping with the security guard who was already romantically involved with one of the Blue Million maids. The maid was furious, and she and Janet had a loud confrontation about the matter.
“你看见林奇杀了她，对吧？说实话。放弃抵抗吧。放弃抵抗，告诉我你看见了。她死的时候你在场，对吧？这就是你逃跑的原因。”无法再隐瞒真相的斯旺克终于崩溃了，承认她一直都是计划的一部分。这一切始于珍妮特开始与一名已经与蓝磨坊旅馆的一名女佣有恋爱关系的保安发生性关系。那名女佣非常愤怒，她和珍妮特就此事发生了激烈的争吵。
At the time, Laurie Swank had feelings for Arthur Piver, the head security guard who was living off-site at the Chemtron guesthouse. It was soon brought to Swank's attention that Janet had also been sleeping with Piver. Swank was livid. Wanting revenge against Janet, she confronted Piver and told him he wasn't the only guard Janet had been falling around with. This information enraged Piver, who in turn labelled Janet a, quote, whore, and said that he would take care of it. He began speaking to some of the other guards and maids who felt wronged by Janet, and they hatched a revenge plan they hoped would humiliate her and, quote, teach her a lesson.
当时，劳里·斯旺克对亚瑟·皮弗有好感，他是住在切姆特隆客房的保安主管。斯旺克很快注意到珍妮特也一直在和皮弗睡觉。斯旺克非常愤怒。为了报复珍妮特，她找到皮弗，告诉他珍妮特不仅和他一个人鬼混。这一信息激怒了皮弗，他反过来称珍妮特为“妓女”，并说他会处理这件事。他开始与一些同样觉得被珍妮特亏待的保安和女佣交谈，他们制定了一个报复计划，希望羞辱她并“给她一个教训”。
The group believed that Janet, quote, thought a lot of herself and needed to, quote, be brought down a few notches. Arthur Piver, Robert Lynch, Laurie Swank, James Nelson, and three other guards gathered in the motel lobby and discussed exactly how to proceed. They decided that the men would convince Janet they were taking her to a surprise party in her honour, and once she agreed to go, they'd call Swank to come in and take over Janet's shift. From there, they would take her to Piver's guesthouse, where they would take turns raping her before eventually taking her life. As they devised the details, it was clear that the men were excited about putting the plan into action.
这群人认为珍妮特“太自以为是”，需要“挫挫锐气”。亚瑟·皮弗、罗伯特·林奇、劳里·斯旺克、詹姆斯·尼尔森和其他三名保安聚集在旅馆大厅，讨论具体如何进行。他们决定，男人们会说服珍妮特，他们要带她去参加一个为她举办的惊喜派对，一旦她同意去，他们就会打电话给斯旺克，让她来接替珍妮特的班。从那里，他们会把她带到皮弗的客房，在那里他们会轮流强奸她，最后夺走她的生命。在制定细节时，很明显男人们对付诸行动感到兴奋。
When the attack was underway, Laurie Swank entered the bedroom to find Janet naked and bound on the bed. She watched as the guards took turns raping her. Swank looked right at Janet, verbally abused her, and cheered the men on. After witnessing Robert Lynch pull on the belt that ultimately killed Janet, Swank said she feared for her own life. Although she vowed never to tell another soul what had happened, she was riddled with guilt. To maintain her innocent facade, she attended Janet's funeral, as did Arthur Piver and James Nelson. Swank left Holland shortly after in the hopes of leaving the secret behind, but fear followed her wherever she went. As the years passed by, Swank considered coming clean, but feared what it would mean for her relationship with her
当袭击开始时，劳里·斯旺克走进卧室，发现珍妮特赤身裸体地被绑在床上。她看着保安们轮流强奸她。斯旺克直视着珍妮特，辱骂她，并为男人们加油。在目睹罗伯特·林奇拉紧最终杀死珍妮特的皮带后，斯旺克说她担心自己的生命安全。虽然她发誓永远不会告诉任何人发生了什么，但她内心充满了内疚。为了维持她无辜的假象，她参加了珍妮特的葬礼，亚瑟·皮弗和詹姆斯·尼尔森也参加了。斯旺克不久后离开了荷兰，希望能把这个秘密抛在脑后，但恐惧如影随形。随着岁月的流逝，斯旺克考虑过坦白，但担心这会对她与
own family. After Lynch's confession, she decided to tell the police the whole truth because it was the right thing to do, and Janet's family deserved closure. With Lynch and Swank confessing, other witnesses at the party also lifted the veil of silence and admitted their knowledge of the crime. One of Arthur Piver's former girlfriends, a chemtron striker named Patty Ward, admitted she had lied when providing an alibi for Piver for the night of the murder. She claimed Piver had forced her to say he was with her, warning she would end up dead on the side of the road if she didn't comply. Ultimately, it took the cold case team nearly two and a half years to uncover the full truth. One thing that continued to astound them was just how many people
自己家人的关系产生什么影响。在林奇供认后，她决定告诉警察全部真相，因为这是正确的做法，珍妮特的家人理应得到一个了结。随着林奇和斯旺克的供认，派对上的其他目击者也揭开了沉默的面纱，承认了他们对犯罪的了解。亚瑟·皮弗的前女友之一，切姆特隆罢工者帕蒂·沃德（Patty Ward）承认，她在为皮弗提供谋杀当晚的不在场证明时撒了谎。她声称皮弗强迫她说他当时和她在一起，并警告如果她不服从，她最终会死在路边。最终，冷案组花了近两年半的时间才揭开全部真相。让他们感到震惊的一件事是，竟然有这么多人
had either participated in, or witnessed the attack on Janet, yet had remained silent for close to 30 years. It seemed almost inconceivable that someone hadn't come forward earlier. A witness who worked as a maid at the Blue Mill Inn provided some insight. She claimed that some of the guards who were involved threatened to kill anyone who spoke out. Over the years, they paid her visits at random to demand she keep her mouth shut, unless she wanted to end up just like Janet. The same thing happened to all six women who attended the party. Another explanation for the ongoing silence was the possibility that incriminating photographs existed of the attack. A photographer named Ronald Wyrick, who had been assigned to
要么参与了，要么目睹了对珍妮特的袭击，却保持了近30年的沉默。有人没有早点站出来，这几乎是不可思议的。一名在蓝磨坊旅馆做女佣的目击者提供了一些见解。她声称，一些参与的保安威胁要杀死任何说出真相的人。多年来，他们随机拜访她，要求她闭嘴，除非她想落得和珍妮特一样的下场。参加派对的所有六名女性都遭遇了同样的事情。对持续沉默的另一种解释是，可能存在袭击的罪证照片。一名叫罗纳德·怀里克（Ronald Wyrick）的摄影师，他被指派去
capture images of the Camtron Strike, had also attended the party. According to Wyrick, while he didn't participate in the attack on Janet, he witnessed the whole thing and had even taken photos of it. He recalled that Janet appeared to be drifting in and out of consciousness and occasionally attempted to break free. Wyrick said, quote, Piver wanted to make sure I had a picture of him and her together. After Janet's murder, Wyrick handed the role of film to another guard, who promised to pass it on to Piver. Wyrick claimed that everyone at the party knew about the photos and lived in fear that Piver could use the photos against them if they ever went to the police. However, a search of Piver's
拍摄切姆特隆罢工的照片，也参加了派对。据怀里克说，虽然他没有参与对珍妮特的袭击，但他目睹了整个过程，甚至还拍了照片。他回忆说，珍妮特看起来意识模糊，偶尔试图挣脱。怀里克说：“皮弗想确保我有一张他和她在一起的照片。”珍妮特遇害后，怀里克把胶卷交给了另一名保安，那人承诺会把它交给皮弗。怀里克声称派对上的每个人都知道这些照片，并生活在恐惧中，担心如果他们去警察局，皮弗会利用这些照片对付他们。然而，对皮弗的
home didn't uncover the photos. If such images existed, they were never found. Robert Lynch, Laurie Swank, Arthur Piver, James Nelson, Freddy Parker, and Anthony Williams were each charged with three felonies, first-degree murder, committing a murder during the commission of a kidnapping, and committing a murder during the commission of criminal sexual conduct. If found guilty, they'd each face a mandatory life sentence with no chance of parole. At the time of Arthur Piver's arrest, the 54-year-old was still living in Muskegon, the same city the Chandlers lived in at the time of Janet's murder. He had been there ever since the Chemtron strike ended.
家进行搜查并没有发现这些照片。如果确实存在这样的照片，它们也从未被找到。罗伯特·林奇、劳里·斯旺克、亚瑟·皮弗、詹姆斯·尼尔森、弗雷迪·帕克和安东尼·威廉姆斯（Anthony Williams）每人都被控三项重罪：一级谋杀罪、在绑架过程中谋杀罪，以及在实施刑事性行为过程中谋杀罪。如果罪名成立，他们每人都将面临强制性的终身监禁，且不得假释。在亚瑟·皮弗被捕时，这位54岁的人仍住在马斯基根（Muskegon），也就是钱德勒一家在珍妮特遇害时居住的城市。自切姆特隆罢工结束以来，他一直住在那里。
Now divorced with two children, Piver denied having anything to do with the crime, and claimed he wasn't even at the party. He told one reporter, I can't believe that everyone that was supposedly there would say I was there. The other accused men also staunchly denied their involvement. 59-year-old James Bubba Nelson was living in West Virginia with his two autistic sons. He was claiming social security benefits when police approached him and placed him under arrest. Nelson admitted to having sexual relations with Janet, but denied having anything to do with her murder. 49-year-old Freddie Parker, who now walked with a cane as a result of diabetes,
现在离婚并有两个孩子的皮弗否认与犯罪有任何关系，并声称他甚至没有参加派对。他告诉一位记者：“我无法相信所有据说在场的人都会说我在场。”其他被指控的男子也坚决否认参与其中。59岁的詹姆斯·“巴巴”·尼尔森（James Bubba Nelson）和他的两个自闭症儿子住在西弗吉尼亚州。当警察找到他并逮捕他时，他正在领取社会保障福利。尼尔森承认与珍妮特发生过性关系，但否认与她的谋杀案有任何关系。49岁的弗雷迪·帕克，由于糖尿病现在拄着拐杖走路，
claimed he moved to West Virginia nine days before Janet's murder took place. Not only was this disproved by multiple witness statements, but a next girlfriend of Parker's who worked as a maid at the Blue Mill Inn said she heard him loudly bragging about his involvement in the crime. The fifth and final guard, Anthony Williams, was extradited from Wisconsin and claimed he wasn't at the party on the night that Janet was killed. As the child dates approached, Robert Lynch agreed to provide a full, detailed confession in exchange for a second-degree murder charge.
声称他在珍妮特遇害前九天搬到了西弗吉尼亚州。这不仅被多名目击者的证词所推翻，而且帕克的一位前女友（曾在蓝磨坊旅馆做女佣）说，她听到他大声吹嘘自己参与了这起犯罪。第五名也是最后一名保安安东尼·威廉姆斯从威斯康星州被引渡回来，并声称珍妮特遇害当晚他不在派对上。随着审判日期临近，罗伯特·林奇同意提供一份完整、详细的供词，以换取二级谋杀罪的指控。
Subsequently, he was sentenced to 40 years in prison, with a minimum of 25 years. At Lynch's sentencing, Janet's parents finally had the chance to address one of the men responsible for their daughter's death. Janet's mother, Glenner, addressed Lynch directly, as she said, You broke our family circle, but it will be complete again in heaven with the Janet. Tell us, what lesson did you teach your family? Janet's father Jim also attempted to address Lynch, but his hands began shaking uncontrollably, and he was so overcome with emotion that he had to be let out of the courtroom. When Robert Lynch was given the opportunity to speak, he mumbled,
随后，他被判处40年监禁，最低服刑25年。在林奇的量刑听证会上，珍妮特的父母终于有机会面对导致他们女儿死亡的凶手之一。珍妮特的母亲格伦纳（Glenner）直接对林奇说：“你打破了我们的家庭圈子，但在天堂里，它会和珍妮特再次完整。告诉我们，你给你的家人上了什么课？”珍妮特的父亲吉姆（Jim）也试图对林奇说话，但他的手开始无法控制地颤抖，他情绪过于激动，不得不被带出法庭。当罗伯特·林奇有机会发言时，他嘟囔道：
I hope the family rests in peace, and I ask forgiveness from Janet. I worked hard for 18 months to see this come to an end, and I hope it does. In exchange for the lesser charge of second-degree murder, Laurie Swank agreed to testify against the guards at trial. With her testimony and Lynch's confession, the defendants barely stood a chance. Regardless, each pleaded not guilty and maintained they weren't at the party and didn't have knowledge of the crime. However, as the trial approached, it was revealed that Lynch wouldn't be taking the stand. He was diagnosed with alcohol-related dementia, and the prosecution
“我希望这个家庭安息，我请求珍妮特的宽恕。我努力工作了18个月才看到这一切结束，我希望它能结束。”为了换取较轻的二级谋杀罪指控，劳里·斯旺克同意在审判中出庭指证这些保安。有了她的证词和林奇的供词，被告几乎没有胜算。尽管如此，每个人都拒不认罪，并坚称他们没有参加派对，也不知道这起犯罪。然而，随着审判临近，有消息称林奇不会出庭作证。他被诊断出患有酒精相关的痴呆症，检方
concluded that he wasn't credible enough to be put before a jury. With no DNA or physical evidence tying the accused man to the crime, the case would have to rely heavily on Laurie Swank's testimony. On October 17, 2007, a bleary-eyed, disheveled-looking Swank took the stand and took the court step-by-step through the events of Janet's murder, from the planning to the attack itself. She spared no details, fully admitting to her role in the plot, as well as to being part of what she called the cheer squad. Swank admitted that she was motivated by jealousy, as Janet was more popular with the guards than she was. The prosecutor said, I have to ask you, because I know the jury's thinking right now.
得出结论，他不足以在陪审团面前作证。由于没有DNA或物证将被告与犯罪联系起来，案件将不得不严重依赖劳里·斯旺克的证词。2007年10月17日，睡眼惺忪、衣衫不整的斯旺克走上证人席，一步步向法庭讲述了珍妮特谋杀案的经过，从策划到袭击本身。她没有遗漏任何细节，完全承认了她在阴谋中的角色，以及作为她所说的“啦啦队”的一员。斯旺克承认她是出于嫉妒，因为珍妮特比她更受保安欢迎。检察官说：“我必须问你，因为我知道陪审团现在在想什么。”
What was going through your head? Why, for God's sake, were you participating in this? Swank replied that she was angry and jealous. When the prosecutor asked how she justified this to herself, Swank responded, I can't. Swank's testimony was bolstered by two former Blue Million maids, Cheryl Ruiz and Diane Marsman, who knew of the plan and also attended the party. Piper's ex-girlfriend, Patty Ward, also testified. Each of the women named Robert Lynch, Arthur Piver, James Nelson, Freddy Parker, and Anthony Williams as being involved. Diane Marsman said, Janet was a mess. She looked very scared. They were raping her. They pretty much all took turns.
“你脑子里在想什么？看在上帝的份上，你为什么要参与其中？”斯旺克回答说她当时很生气，也很嫉妒。当检察官问她如何向自己证明这一点时，斯旺克回答说：“我无法证明。”斯旺克的证词得到了两名前蓝磨坊旅馆女佣谢丽尔·鲁伊斯（Cheryl Ruiz）和黛安·马斯曼（Diane Marsman）的支持，她们知道这个计划并参加了派对。皮弗的前女友帕蒂·沃德也出庭作证。每位女性都指认罗伯特·林奇、亚瑟·皮弗、詹姆斯·尼尔森、弗雷迪·帕克和安东尼·威廉姆斯参与其中。黛安·马斯曼说：“珍妮特当时一团糟。她看起来非常害怕。他们在强奸她。他们几乎轮流来。”
In Robert Lynch's confession, he noted that Janet's eyes had been glazed over during the attack, as though she'd been drugged. However, a toxicology test done after Janet's body was found revealed no traces of drugs in her system, nor did anyone give testimony to her being drugged. It was determined the glazed look in Janet's eyes was most likely a physical reaction to shock. Throughout the trial, it emerged that as many as 12 guards had participated in the attack on Janet, either by being part of the planning session or in the gang rape itself. State prosecutors were faced with the decision about whether or not to pursue charges against other individuals. Ultimately, they decided only to charge Piver, Nelson, Lynch, Parker, and Williams
在罗伯特·林奇的供词中，他提到珍妮特的眼睛在袭击过程中呆滞，仿佛被下了药。然而，在发现珍妮特尸体后进行的毒理学测试显示，她的体内没有药物痕迹，也没有人作证说她被下了药。经确定，珍妮特眼睛呆滞的样子很可能是休克引起的生理反应。在整个审判过程中，事实浮出水面，多达12名保安参与了对珍妮特的袭击，要么是参与了策划会议，要么是参与了轮奸本身。州检察官面临着是否要对其他人提起指控的决定。最终，他们决定只起诉皮弗、尼尔森、林奇、帕克和威廉姆斯，
as they had the strongest evidence against them. However, prosecutors remained open to the possibility that further people could be charged in the future. On November 1, the jury returned to the courtroom to deliver their verdicts. Glenner Chandler burst into tears and buried her face in her husband's shoulder, as the jury found all four of the defendants guilty of two counts each of felony murder. Arthur Piver was also convicted of first-degree murder, while Freddie Parker, James Nelson, and Anthony Williams were each convicted of second-degree murder. The four men sat stone faced while members of their families broke down. Freddie Parker's sister was so overcome with emotion that paramedics had to come to her aid. Meanwhile, Jim Chandler whispered,
因为他们掌握了对他们最有利的证据。然而，检察官对未来可能起诉更多人持开放态度。11月1日，陪审团回到法庭宣读裁决。格伦纳·钱德勒泪流满面，把脸埋在丈夫的肩膀上，陪审团裁定所有四名被告每人犯有两项重罪谋杀罪。亚瑟·皮弗还被判一级谋杀罪，而弗雷迪·帕克、詹姆斯·尼尔森和安东尼·威廉姆斯每人被判二级谋杀罪。四名男子面无表情地坐着，而他们的家人则崩溃了。弗雷迪·帕克的妹妹情绪过于激动，医护人员不得不赶来救助。与此同时，吉姆·钱德勒低声说：
Amen. A former detective who had worked the original case was brought to tears, commenting outside of court. It's about time. I'm sorry it took so long. Holland police chief John Krytov hoped the verdict would bring some relief for Janet's family, remarking, I just hope and pray they can have peace and closure finally with this conviction. This is going to help them, but probably it won't close it in their hearts. The sentencing hearing commenced in December 2007. Jim and Glenner Chandler bravely fronted the court, with the gym saying, Glenner and I have been waiting 28 years for this day. They thought they got away with it, and for the most part, they did.
“阿门。”一名曾参与最初案件的退休侦探热泪盈眶，在法庭外评论道：“是时候了。很抱歉花了这么长时间。”荷兰警察局长约翰·克里托夫（John Krytov）希望这一判决能为珍妮特的家人带来一些安慰，他评论道：“我只是希望并祈祷他们最终能通过这次定罪获得平静和了结。这会有所帮助，但可能无法抚平他们心中的伤痛。”量刑听证会于2007年12月开始。吉姆和格伦纳·钱德勒勇敢地面对法庭，吉姆说：“格伦纳和我已经为这一天等了28年。他们以为他们逃脱了惩罚，在很大程度上，他们确实做到了。”
They thanked the cold case team for their tireless efforts in solving Janet's case and for the care and respect they'd shown throughout the investigation. Glenner said she and her husband had accepted they had to let Janet go, remarking, We've left her in the Lord's hands. The four defendants avoided looking in the Chandler's direction. None of the men opted to address the court before they were each sentenced to life in prison without the possibility of parole. Outside court, a teary Jim Chandler said, What can they say? They all say they weren't there and they're innocent.
他们感谢冷案组在破获珍妮特案件中所做的孜孜不倦的努力，以及他们在整个调查过程中表现出的关怀和尊重。格伦纳说，她和丈夫已经接受了必须放手珍妮特的事实，并评论道：“我们已经把她交托在主的手中。”四名被告避免看向钱德勒一家。在被判处终身监禁且不得假释之前，没有一个人选择向法庭发言。法庭外，泪流满面的吉姆·钱德勒说：“他们能说什么呢？他们都说他们不在场，他们是无辜的。”
As a Christian, I just say we should probably forgive. However, you have to ask for forgiveness, and none of these arrogant people showed remorse, much less asked for forgiveness. Glenner added, I do feel sorry for the parents and families of the men. I can't feel sorry for the men. I can't hate them, because that would make me just like them. Each of the four men subsequently attempted to appeal their convictions, arguing that the witness testimonies had been unreliable, and that there was no physical evidence tying them to the crime. All of their appeals were denied.
“作为一名基督徒，我只是说我们或许应该宽恕。然而，你必须请求宽恕，而这些傲慢的人没有表现出悔意，更不用说请求宽恕了。”格伦纳补充说：“我确实为这些人的父母和家人感到难过。我无法为这些人感到难过。我不能恨他们，因为那样会让我变得和他们一样。”四名男子随后都试图对他们的定罪提出上诉，辩称证人证词不可靠，且没有物证将他们与犯罪联系起来。他们的上诉全部被驳回。
In March 2013, Arthur Piver passed away in prison on his 61st birthday, after serving just five years of his life sentence. Three years later, in 2016, Laurie Swank was released on parole. In June 2020, James Nelson also passed away from natural causes. That leaves just three of the six individuals convicted of Janet Chandler's murder still behind bars as of early 2022. For the Hope College students who were involved in making the Who Kill Janet Chandler documentary, nothing could have prepared them for the events that unfolded as a result of their project. One student remarked, I learned to appreciate life a lot more, that's
2013年3月，亚瑟·皮弗在服刑五年后，于61岁生日当天在狱中去世。三年后的2016年，劳里·斯旺克获得假释。2020年6月，詹姆斯·尼尔森也因自然原因去世。截至2022年初，六名因珍妮特·钱德勒谋杀案被定罪的人中，只有三人仍在狱中。对于参与制作《谁杀了珍妮特·钱德勒》纪录片的霍普学院（Hope College）学生来说，没有什么能让他们为项目结果所引发的事件做好准备。一名学生评论道：“我学会了更加珍惜生命，这是肯定的。”
for sure. I mean, the more you research death, the more you appreciate living day after day. For Sarah Hartman, the student who would nervously interview Janet's parents for the film, the experience taught her that something that seems small to begin with can have a huge impact. You never know what's going to happen, Sarah said. The outcome had a profound impact on David Shock, the associate professor who came up with the idea to make the documentary. Shock left teaching and founded an organization called Delayed Justice, in which he uses his film and research skills to shine a light on other unsolved crimes. His work has helped bring about charges in another unsolved murder.
“我的意思是，你研究死亡越多，你就越珍惜日复一日的生活。”对于萨拉·哈特曼（Sarah Hartman）——那位紧张地采访珍妮特父母的学生来说，这段经历让她明白，起初看起来很小的事情可能会产生巨大的影响。“你永远不知道会发生什么，”萨拉说。这一结果对大卫·肖克（David Shock）产生了深远的影响，他是提出制作这部纪录片的副教授。肖克离开了教学岗位，创立了一个名为“延迟的正义”（Delayed Justice）的组织，利用他的电影和研究技能来揭露其他未决案件。他的工作帮助促成了对另一桩未决谋杀案的指控。
Driven by the need to see fairness and justice restored for grieving families, Shock operates under the premise, somebody knows something, somebody always knows something. A year after the trial, the Chandler family attempted to sue the Wackenheart Corporation for damages relating to mental pain and anguish, funeral expenses and punitive damages. They argued that several of the security guards were unfit for employment and the company was negligent in failing to run adequate background checks or providing suitable supervision. The lawsuit was thrown out due to it being lodged outside of Michigan's Statute of Limitations. In a 2008 interview with NBC's Dateline, journalist Victoria Cordary asked Jim and
出于对为悲伤家庭恢复公平和正义的渴望，肖克在“有人知道些什么，总有人知道些什么”的前提下运作。审判一年后，钱德勒一家试图起诉Wackenhart公司，要求赔偿与精神痛苦、丧葬费用和惩罚性赔偿相关的损失。他们辩称，几名保安不适合受雇，公司在进行充分背景调查或提供适当监督方面存在疏忽。由于该诉讼是在密歇根州的诉讼时效之外提出的，因此被驳回。在2008年接受NBC《日界线》（Dateline）采访时，记者维多利亚·科达里（Victoria Cordary）问吉姆和
Glenna Chandler if they thought justice had been served for their daughter. Glenna answered, yes, for Janet. These other ones have to live with what they did, but we know where she's at and we know that she's with our Lord. Jim disagreed, replying, no, there's closure, but I don't think there will ever be justice. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
格伦纳·钱德勒，他们是否认为他们的女儿得到了正义。格伦纳回答说：“是的，为了珍妮特。其他人必须带着他们所做的事情生活，但我们知道她在哪里，我们知道她和我们的主在一起。”吉姆不同意，回答说：“不，有了了结，但我认为永远不会有正义。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。